اصبح هذا المشهد الاحتفالي في مدينه
الرياض خلال الاشهر الماضيه اعتياديا نظرا
لكثره نقل الشركات العالميه مقراتها
وافتتاح مكاتب لها في العاصمه ما جعله
هنالك الطلب عالي على سوق المكاتب لا سيما
من فئه الف
[موسيقى]
على ايقاع العرضه النجديه يحتفي الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه الادويه السويسريه روج
بافتتاح مقر شركه بحضور وزير الاستثمار
خالد الفالح في لاسم ثاني حيث تجتمع اكثر
من 50 شركه عالميه واقليميه غالبيتها في
القطاع الطبي اهميه الانتقال
العاصمه الرياض وافتتاح المكتب
في وسط الرياض اليوم له اهميه لشركه رشا
اليوم واعطاء الرساله الواضحه همم باهميه
النص من الاستثمار بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه لحتى همم هل انفيشن والابتكارات
الجديده اللي همم بتطلع من رش تكون موجوده
باثر على وقت للمرضى سميت المنطقه التي
جذبت الشركات الدوليه بالاسم ثاني تيامنا
باسم وادي الشهير الذي اصبح تحفه معماريه
في قلب الرياض اتخذته الشركات الطبيه هو
المستشفيات مقر لها على مساحه 1500 متر
مربع اخترنا هذا الموقع همم للاكسس
سبيليتي او الوصول السهل فيها شفنا انه
المكان هذا ممكن يكون قريب من شركائنا من
المستشفيات ومن الوزارات والوصول له بشكل
افضل وكذلك المجمع يوفر بيئه جميله
للموظفين يوفر خدمات جميله للموظفين وشفنا
انه قد يكون هذا افضل مكان نحط فيه المكتب
الرئيسي والحمد لله اتوقع انه توفقنا فيه
الطلب لا زال يتصاعد على قطاع المكاتب
الفاخره بعد انعام خلال السنوات الماضيه
من عكس على جوده المشاريع مثل وادي الليثى
الذي يتوقع ان يصبح رافدا اقتصاديا لمدينه
الرياض
عبد المحسن الحربي العربي